zwei euro 20 für die energie jetzt habe
ich noch 81 aber ich habe eine gute
nummer so ist es auch gut zum
krankenhaus zu fahren so leute mal sehen
guten morgen
[Musik]
hey was geht ab dann herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja das schafft
natürlich geht es gut heute mit einer
wirklich sehr spontan und video idee die
mir gestern eingefallen ist und das habe
ich gestern abend auch schon so halten
in die tat umgesetzt ich erkläre ich mal
kurz worum es geht also ich bin gestern
nach hause gefahren und wir haben hier
in unserer kleinen stadt so ein sondern
automaten wirst du eigentlich nur zwei
automaten und da gibt es viele sachen
ich habe allerdings noch nie so wirklich
geschafft was da geb ich habe aber nie
eingekauft er kann man normalerweise
auch so grillsachen kaufen und so weiter
und ich bin auch die unfassbar geniale
idee kommen einfach mal zu sagen ey du
fährst jetzt dahin und kaufst du ein
paar sachen daraus ein und versuchte
passt der dinge zu kaufen um sich damit
dann 24 stunden führen lernen ich weiß
du eine idee kann natürlich nur wieder
von mir kommen aber ich fand das
eigentlich echt cool so was habe ich
noch nie gesehen und deswegen bin ich
gestern spontan
eigentlich waren draußen überhaupt nicht
eigentlich echt krass
gestern war es vorgestern war es 30 grad
und heute schon sagen so 18
auf jeden fall bin ich gestern
losgefahren und wie das aussah das seht
ihr jetzt so leute also ich habe gerade
diesen automaten gesehen wird natürlich
auf die idee gekommen und vater jetzt
hin
ich habe noch nie diesen automaten
benutzt das ist auch der einzige den wir
hier in der stadt haben und ich habe
absolut keine ahnung was da drin ist
aber da ist schon relativ groß ich
glaube das sind doch zwei nebeneinander
zumindest kann man auch so grillsachen
kaufen im sommer ja deswegen sehen wir
uns gleich hier haben wir das ding
eigentlich ist hier auch noch einer oder
automat ist defekt mitten in der nacht
mal gucken wie viel geld ich dabei habe
ich glaube hier funktionieren sogar
scheine ich hab noch zehn euro hier drin
15 euro genutzt sonst auch so ein
bisschen kleingeld
was haben wir denn jetzt vier euro ok so
als erstes land zwei euro 20 für die
energie jetzt habe ich noch 81 aber ich
habe eine gute nummer
das hier ist auch gut also leute ich
habe jetzt gerade acht euro
eingeschmissen ich will jetzt einiges
raus zeige ich dass gleiches gleich
alter toffifee es einfach fünf euro
alles klar
dass nutella tv eigentlich hatte ich
noch einen kaffee so lösche ich habe
jetzt gerade noch kartoffelsalat
gefunden für zwei euro 20 da habe ich
irgendwann nicht gesehen und der kaffee
ich glaube dass eben nicht rausgekommen
also die beiden schnellsten zeit mehr
als 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 9 sachen davon
drei getränke eigentlich wollte ich zwei
wasser das andere wasser klemmt jetzt
allerdings habe ich kaputt gemacht ich
jetzt schlafen morgen beginnt das ganze
später so leute wir haben jetzt halb
zehn morgens und ich hab noch nicht
gefrühstückt ist ja auch klar
und deswegen wird es jetzt zeit meine
hand übrigens ordentlich gemacht hab
sehr wahrscheinlich gerade gesehen ich
habe mir hier einmal nutella trikot
geholt das war sogar echt günstig das
hat in diesem automaten 21 gekostet und
dieser starbucks café latte kostet
eigentlich im supermarkt 160 und in dem
automaten hat er 190 gekostet ich meine
der liebling 63 will jetzt also nicht zu
100 prozent aber so viel teurer war das
gar nicht arbeitet ist ungefähr 20 denn
ich habe ewig schon keiner mehr gegessen
früher machte ich das richtig gerne habe
ich mich mal richtig gefreut wenn uns
das gab aber schaut euch das machen
das ist eigentlich echt gut gemacht sagt
und schon kann man trinken ja leute ich
erst jetzt auch das ist ja eigentlich
ein angebrachtes frühstück natürlich
diese täler thurgau packung ist
eigentlich viel zu wenig habe ich habe
ja noch mehr aber ich fand ich jetzt
einfach an weil ein großer starker kerl
so wie ich braucht natürlich noch viel
mehr kalorien als das hier also bis
gleich ich habe das kulturhaus
geflüchtet sondern meine haare und dann
mussten wir schauen was die gäste haben
gekauft habt ich habe es irgendwie fast
schon wieder vergessen haben kekse und
so ich muss heute auf jeden fall noch
meinen koffer
weil ich heute abend noch mal nach köln
fahren und morgen danach wieder morgen
genauen morgen danach berlin fliege
allerdings von düsseldorf bis samstag
und ich muss heute auf jeden fall noch
eine menge gelernt weil ich bei chassoul
phasen habe für meine uni
ansonsten habe ich keinen plan was der
tagen heute so bringen wird aber wir
werden sehen also leute ich habe schon
ein bisschen gelernt habe der
weihnachtsmann mikado zu exzessen kann
ich mir auch schon ewig nicht mehr
gekauft ich habe jetzt allerdings
gedacht damit man schon mal so eine
kleine grundlage hat probiert einmal
hier wenn man so keine ahnung also
diesen kartoffelsalat natürlich ist ganz
wichtig dazu zu sagen gibt es nicht
üblicherweise einen automaten gibt es
dann nur weil das halt der automat von
seinem lebensmittelladen ist ich glaube
das ist doch eigentlich selber gemacht
zwei euro 10 wirklich fair finde ich und
hier dieses wasser hat 90 cent gekostet
ja also eigentlich gar nicht mal so
schlecht natürlich wird man heute abend
irgendwas fehlt
ich hatte noch irgendwas für heute abend
kommen sollen aber vielleicht vielleicht
dennoch bleiben keine ahnung so also
deutschen machen und auf das schmeckt
mir ganz normaler doppelte also 350
gramm
wenn man sich eigentlich nicht
beschweren sich erst jetzt einfach mal
schnell auf so alt mittagsmahlzeit und
dann zeige ich euch was ich noch so hat
heute gefehlt gerade auf also ich habe
jetzt viel besser lag ungefähr so ja
bisher mehr als die hälfte gästen jetzt
hier und mal da reingepackt ich habe
jetzt hier noch die cola gekauft ich
habe ihn monster trinkt gekauft und noch
mit max und dann noch das hier und das
wasser und das ist gleich mehr
deswegen haben wir ein kleines problem
weil ich glaube nicht dass das an
erreichen wird ich frage mich gerade was
ich mir gestern dabei gedacht hab ich
meine dass solch ein abendessen keks
oder so leute ich bin gerade ein
bisschen am lernen ich habe
schon gesagt ich schreibe wieder
klausuren und es ist ja eigentlich immer
ziemlich gut wenn man dann halt auch
möglichst früh anfängt ich glaube die
ersten zwei wochen ein bisschen habe ich
schon einmal diese nicht mehr aufgemacht
und die cola wollte jetzt gleich noch
einen ruf eltern fahren und ich habe
gerade total konzentrations langweilig
und zwei stunden hier sitze also das
spiel so leute ich habe jetzt gerade
noch meine großeltern besucht und bin
auf die geniale idee gekommen eigentlich
mal zum krankenhaus zu fahren weil die
haben glaube ich echt viele automaten
ich war da schon mal und die haben nicht
alle funktioniert aber da gab es eine
menge ich weiß nicht ich einfach mal hin
mal gucken was es da so gibt ich hoffe
auch was vernünftiges zu essen also bis
gleich so leute mal sehen
okay ich hab das auch schaut euch mal
wie ich das war nicht so gut
naja das packen wir nochmal es gab ein
automat gab es nur essen
ich habe jetzt noch so ein joghurt
bekommen mit vanillegeschmack alter 500
gramm okay aber das ist so glaube ich so
der typische krankenhaus joghurt wenn
man halt so vanille und kriegt und
irgendwie so deutsche linus oder die
muss man grad kochen
wer geht ins krankenhaus zum automaten
kauft sich nudeln die er zu hause kocht
dafür man kann jetzt sofort essen ok
dass wir auf irgend ein bisschen dumm
weil dann würden wir wahrscheinlich
deutschland ab laufen ja das hätte ich
dann hätte ich was heute abend
ich weiß einfach nach hause gleich
diese beiden sachen habe ich sowieso
noch ganz gut ski fährt und schlafe ich
nicht ein weil ich bin irgendwie echt
ein bisschen müde
und ja dann sind da noch diese hart
gefrorenen tortellini so oder so also
die autobahn ist heute erstaunlich leer
irgendwie hatte ich gestern an das
gefühl ich habe richtig viel gekauft und
jetzt fällt mir auf ich hatte noch
diesen pudding beim hätten diese
plätzchen und das war krieg nicht zurück
nach köln auf kühlt sich leider nichts
deswegen sage ich einfach mal chillen
die im übrigens bald gibt es einen song
viel spaß so ich muss mich ja selbst
auto fahren konzentrieren auch wenn ich
gerade nur 90 fahre trotzdem
die kamera ist er wieder weg gelegt habe
ich mich bedingt alles tragen da
angekommen
ich habe diesen also fast die ganzen
monster drink leer getrunken das sind ja
0,5 liter und ich muss so heftig pisten
man muss ja von energydrinks eben mal
schnell aufs tor aber der war nicht so
lecker wie red bull auf keinen fall aber
er ist auf jeden fall gewirkt so leute
ich bin hier der küche vor allem das
lustig macht diese hat woran hat die
tortellini ist schon mal gekocht wurde
doch immer das ist koch stellt eine
minute und ich komme hier rein und da
liegt einfach noch eine pizza von eben
die heute eigentlich extra für mich über
war und ich mache jetzt hier diese torte
ließ so eine minute ist schon rum
die stinken irgendwie ein bisschen ist
aber eigentlich lecker eine fünf geben
name sagt schon 10
ich hätte es schlechter gedacht all die
leute ich erst dass jetzt in ruhe und
dann habe ich noch diesen krankenhaus
roding oder passiert ist damit ja mal
gespannt alles gleich so leute
wir haben jetzt schon den nächsten tag
und zwar bin ich schon am video
schneiden ich habe irgendwie voll
vergessen das ist endet zu machen und
bin irgendwie gestern einfach eingepennt
wir haben jetzt hier noch diesen ja
krankenhaus vanillepudding oder was auch
immer das sein soll deswegen würde ich
dir noch ganz schnell einmal aufmachen
er ist leider nicht nur der ich liebe ja
wandel schaut euch das an
ich habe ihn jetzt gestern hielt gar
nicht mehr gebraucht ich habe gestern
recht wenig gegessen
aber man sieht ja sofort bin ich
krankenhaus ja ich muss mir jetzt echt
geiles video noch schnell zu ende karten
und dann geht es los nach berlin ich war
auch schon länger nicht mehr in berlin
also richtig gut gefallen und last man
vettel noch nach oben da und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder da gibt's schon im
1400 video und hat rein